IAIN MURRAY: Welcome.
I'm Iain Murray, and I'm a Professor of Electrical
and Computer Engineering at Curtin University.
And I'll be taking you through the Introduction to The Internet of Things.
So what we'll be looking at in this course that you've just started
is we'll have an overview of The Internet of Things--
the businesses that can help, some examples and case
studies of The Internet of Things in the real world.
We'll then move on and look at, what are the things?
It's an internet of things.
What are those things?
And then we'll have a look at how we connect these things together--
the network that underlies The Internet of Things.
Following on from that, we'll look at how we program specifically
for The Internet of Things, and the kind of languages
and how we handle the big data that's involved and how we store it.
We'll then move on to that very important aspect--
the security and privacy issues of The Internet of Things.
And finally, we'll look at the design process.
Right so, generally, that's The Internet of Things.
Let's now have a look at some applications and case studies
of The Internet of Things in the real world.